[Music]
three two one action
hey guys welcome back to off-the-record
where we talk about whatever we want and
today we have leaned that dong here
she's the Canadian youtuber she's really
funny make sure to check out her stuff
nice to see you here cool nice to meet
y'all I met you before
Canadians say y'all's yeah I guess I say
y'all's yeah what's up y'all's yeah does
anyone ever said that your last name is
dong and then then that that's kind of
funny yes elementary school they're like
hey Linda do you need to have a dong
race do you think that helped you in
into comedy yes I guess you just like
constantly getting picked on mmm how do
they pick on you
besides isn't it dong the dong thing's
pretty good a good opening it's a good
opening because I think a lot of
Vietnamese people have like trans our
new wins but then my name is dong I knew
someone with fat [ __ ] oh wow yeah like
bi see like big and then pH eighty fat
[ __ ] yeah it have that's funny name
your kid [ __ ] board and our comedian
now I guess or something yeah I guess so
yeah well just give me getting something
hard do you think you'd do that for your
kids uh oh I might I might I might yeah
I like how you think you have a choice
in your kids names that's funny to me
wait are you serious yeah but I really
put my foot down on this one wait they
already have it they already haven't
yeah yeah [ __ ] foot that Nicki Nicki
picked no but you'll see cuz it you when
you hear it you're gonna die o-negative
pick this [ __ ] what is it all I can say
it they're gonna have a name reveal but
we know they'll tell you offer we Rinna
we're gonna save that for a thumbnail I
think I know what it is you do tell me
Barbara Walters I know again can we
guess what do you know well I'll take
you're right oh my god you guys get it
right also I know a secret you know what
it is I never told you it's polyester
why would you say
it's an itchy fabric that look if I was
like it's got to be something that
Steven needs in the other what's the
polyester well Esther is a real name but
if you add Steve to it then you put the
poly and it's polyester why am i poly
what the heli because you like - like
goof it up a little bit like Pauly Shore
got paperclip and then father B yeah is
JoJo's new name is kids paperclip oh we
decided for him because he's just a fair
David decided David and myself
I'll get David into something and you
know they have a baby right yeah they
mistaken you know thank you and I named
him Tori's exactly I think it's a better
name that's a good man you know why
isn't right you know tortilla rice beat
me to the punch no okay no I don't want
it in comedy I don't want to get picked
on is it funny I think your kid would be
I think the name silkworm would fit that
makes a lot of sense yeah all right kid
our kid or his kid no here's mine Oh
yours it's all right go right go yeah
talking like a biker Riker Linda when
did you move here from Canada oh I
didn't move I'm just here sometimes
during the year it's like once every
year you just come visit or what yeah I
thought you're American this whole time
because I met you in America yeah I met
you at your apartment yeah it's like
film but you have an apartment and you
don't live here oh no my friend's
apartment oh you come here a couple
times a month or something I once like
once a month
not once a month it like one month to do
this yeah how'd you get started doing
Vince again yeah I just kind of like
started doing YouTube videos cuz I've
always liked like writing and stuff and
so yeah just kind of started there like
that that's tight yeah do you have any
hobbies
every tuber I know has [ __ ] no
hobbies because they're so busy on
YouTube all day except for you oh I have
hobbies - what's your hobby other things
wrong I like to read I like to go hiking
I like to play piano
those are hobbies I'm on his [ __ ] day
profile I like to long speech literally
yeah wit dogs
I think frisbee si playing like a
frisbee Li you play with West cuz he's
like hardcore into that [ __ ] is that
what
ultimate my friends video you like
weekly like a week yeah weekly thing
catching and throwing like well you do
oh yeah you can yes basically glad what
is you throw and you run for it and then
you catch it oh yeah like football so
you teammates are passing you're trying
to make it to the goal yeah do you have
dogs on your team we don't that would be
actually they'll be really good if we
did that would be you I have the dogs
catch it and I'll throw it yeah dude I
would replace humans with dogs because
that way better at the game they can't
throw it though Oh put their teeth is so
cool yes and whip is it five on five or
three on three oh yeah it's usually like
like sometimes like six one six and they
try to make it past a line we throw the
frisbee to a call yeah yeah the other
goal so it's kind of like soccer so I
throw it into the course about the
ending point it just has to hit a net it
doesn't have to be caught by a person
but husby caught by a person in the
indigo so kind of like it's a mix of
like soccer and football are their
goalies no they should have goalies just
make slap that plate on the ground
there's a lot you look at concussions
actually from ultimate dangerous oh I
know actually like there's so many
people I know they're injured is it good
they're running toward it and then they
hit each other in the head
yeah like well they're trying to hit
each other oh the frisbee cuz frisbees
flying and I was trying to you know I
was on his hands let's like rugby it's
pretty it gets pretty intense was the
next hundred-point
this sounds like a game I would like to
play yeah how do you hurt I was running
for the like of opponent we're running
for the first beat and we both jumped
for it to like shut it well I just want
to watch that sounds hilarious yeah no
it actually went end and then he stepped
on my foot with his cleats
oh [ __ ] serious helmet Alamut you're
like yeah we're gonna help us - yeah no
I feel like helmets are good because
there's a lot of people who get
concussions from it bike helmets or like
football helmets
I could have bike helmet bike helmets be
cool cuz football how much against these
mine well you can't breathe yeah you can
oh yeah ultimate I feel like get the
whip your head around a lot you do yeah
how long have you been doing that um I
started again like just like well it's
been like three years or so yeah are you
serious about the Queen she hasn't made
any jokes in no it's just that Bart
finds it so silly
oh no Everclear too because like where
the run on like grass field yeah where
do you think they run yeah but it's like
you know when you're playing like lead
soccer with your friends sometimes you
know just it's just a friendly game but
I didn't know that you've never played
lead or made your pain and there's like
a trophies and their [ __ ] at the end of
it they were cleats in league soccer
yeah I mean like I knew I picked up
games you know like no she didn't say
pick up a league and then you repeatedly
Bart is such a dick he would beat the UV
on the side of the field during your
your Ultimate Frisbee thing and he but
whoa you guys wear cleats you guys take
this pretty serious huh they're like
yeah we were here aren't we ass all you
[ __ ] pretty hard at this good I
played league football and you pay and
then people like have to pick you for a
team I get serious [ __ ] you played
football volleyball well I didn't know
there was a women's locally all of a
sudden I saw her in a Raiders [ __ ]
uniform with the wah I mean Mexicans
love the Raiders we do but yeah okay
sorry cowboy cowboy sorry it's true I
should have said Cowboys like you guys
playing ultimate one day and just like
you if you play with this guy make sure
he's on your team because you're gonna
die yeah the charity Ultimate Frisbee
game yeah I'll call play yeah my
celebrity charity youtube celebrity
charity yeah that's right America
Toronto playing basketball yeah did you
kick ass
no I didn't I was really intimidated I
think I got really scared everyone was
most fast I was remember like a part
where Bart was running and then everyone
just backed away and he just ran too
yeah I feel like I remember Jason Cheng
was standing boss a block down he's like
yeah he just like eating dream that was
me playing basketball in middle school
dude [ __ ] that [ __ ] I was like yo who
guys coming at me like like like that
like you gonna be the guy running
through because yeah I was there just to
get rebounds but that's it yeah like
they recruited me like everyone runs to
the opposite side and you just wait you
have no idea you have no idea that the
hell that I was in know so I would I
couldn't dribble it all right so I would
try to dribble it and they'd be like oh
no and then you you would see the ball
hit my foot and then just give your best
effort that's why I got lost improved
after all but that's because everyone
also the team was semi good and I was I
went from [ __ ] to like okay he can
throw the ball now and not [ __ ]
everything up throw the ball yeah pass
it pass it as soon as he gets it
some pass it Steve passes right splits
cuz I was tall right so she hasn't
passed over the guy's head I was like ah
[ __ ] sided it was nuts man I was should
not play sports but I'll play ultimate
with you all can I be on your team
yeah sure what part of Canada are you
from I think Hoover I want to go so bad
I heard there's like really good ass
restaurants there because all the Hong
Kong refugees like go there and like
make really good restaurants is that
like you've coast of the West because I
always get China is the west coast
yeah he's co-sister on okay a lot of
French people yes quite a bit quite a
few but I can't tell I just hear them
talking jumbly words I'm on my god boys
[ __ ] oh I forget there's like France
inside Canada but they had their own
kind of French I heard that it
it's not as a holy no offence France but
you don't I mean how they have that
[ __ ] dead tone to it
like oh what's the difference in the
French's it kind of like that actually
but like I feel like the tones are just
different do they teach you French oh
yeah yeah you know French I was like
very a little bit but then yeah in high
school we had to learn French
cuz it's everywhere right every sign I
see it's like English and then I see
French I guess you guys are learned I
guess more like Spanish English hell
yeah we know English
go home failed that a couple times Oh
wasn't good at much they don't really
teach us Spanish we just absorb it it's
like an extra like a class yeah it's not
a mandatory class cuz French was
mandatory for my school cuz Canada's
nice English was mandatory for mine all
schools are like that no French in
Vancouver yeah that's what you can pick
French is mandatory till like a certain
grade and then or you can pick them
after that Japanese or Japanese or
French what do kids do in Vancouver when
the board I feel like like people like
to go like to the waters and just chill
smoke up ok smoke up there you go okay
wait they're just going to the waters
and just putting their I hope we can't
do this past 8:30 though my mom get
pissed she's like let me see your feet
are they wet but ya know I feel like
that because they have a lot of like
forestry and nature so I'll be late to
school thinking or stuff there's a lot
of that like just chilling and in a
sense up in the summer till like
midnight to like yeah to like ten oh
[ __ ] yeah I would hate that with my son
and that go though father you sleep like
the only thing that they you're really
into yeah and frisbee oh yeah like a
Dave job kind of thing oh I did have a
day job it was like my contract work I
was like assistant casting director yeah
so that was a different world it was
like I had a boss as like 9:06
was like help casting for out the TV
they got she throws people like cattle
you understand no the people who come
into auditions it's like a Cheatham I
didn't get like like a bunch of like
like I saw Oh Oh Canada massage them got
make sure tenderize the meats and
decision I think they have their own
home section you know we're so barbaric
compared to Canadians we didn't even get
the oh oh yeah it's not even the same
over there that's so nice hey Vanessa
saying over there go sometimes you don't
treat anything like you don't treat
cattle cattle they were treated better
than humans here yeah what's the same
then how do you thirty treat how do you
what do you call something that you just
don't care about and it's like come in
and come out there you go revolving door
or do you treat them like maple trees
you use them to get to get them into
maple up but they hug them they hug the
cheese [ __ ] it's a revolving door it's
something that doesn't have feelings
that they can't hurt oh I know I know I
know Canada team D who do you treat like
hockey pucks yeah that's your just like
ongoing hockey puck hockey puts over
there what the same like when you treat
something like [ __ ] what's the same
thing you know they nice to hockey pucks
do just like a a rug I'm gonna rug like
a carpets like you walk along more guys
jumping out for a hockey puck to hug
like yeah okay so she said a rug use
that reference wrong but you know you
walk all over them Universal yeah I
don't know yes in it like yeah the
cattle thing I'm like home did you treat
the actors like rugs then how about that
no well I guess with me I don't I
understand like acting and stuff I
wasn't like it's really hard so I'm Way
too much empathy girl I guess that's a
Canadian trait that I do not understand
even at like 559 p.m. you're still
really nice to them and they suck I
guess because I say everyone is like a
different a different experience every
person all right because if you see
everyone that's like the same it's just
like that's not fair yeah you barbarian
okay what if that's not my problem
what is it in the Canadian water that
makes you love people I know
like what what happened we want to
change I think what it is is maybe the
temperate like temperate on weather is
because we have like rain and Sun so I
feel like when we have like when it's
like you don't have no rain is what it
is like because then we appreciate the
Sun more so I don't know that's what
Seattle has a lot of rain and it also
has a lot of suicide yeah Seattle's like
Vancouver there's no ballet don't have
that much Sun you look out the window
spoil your screensaver out there right
yeah pretty much it's HD out there and
that'll do it does it or leaves turn red
here if it wants to saw we don't let
them if a graffiti artist sprays on it
oh I see red leaves one time where dude
though there's like a couple trees in
our neighborhood that for some reason
get seasons but then the other ones
don't get seasons they don't have good
reception yeah I feel them in Delhi okay
there's more seasons in in Texas I think
and I hear California just the desert oh
that's hospitality because they actually
have seasons yeah and barbecue mm-hmm
they're nicer than California they are
my neighbors barbecue right now man and
I'm like [ __ ] I need to barbecue cuz I
do you smell it and then I just like man
my wife's a vegan so you you barbecue
more like [ __ ] alone wait what
there's no point in barbecuing if you're
not gonna eat with your purse I know but
I've seen you put there was like a
someone was doing a pizza and I seen you
put an apple pie in the same oven with
the pizza so I'm just my bone that you
would even go Steve look great yep I got
the more started falling through I'm
sorry have to see is Linda no you will
roast me I know I roasted myself in this
video I failed Spanish I'm not good at
basketball but I was shunned shunned and
now you're right yeah you're right I
couldn't make an apple pie you didn't
even have to make it that's the crazier
part it was already made you just needed
to warm it up and that [ __ ] was just
like a mess what just Brett like just
the [ __ ] what do you call it the he
probably took it out of the bowl I don't
know why it doesn't it come with
aluminum he does
I don't know why he did that I took it
out of you I wasn't sure and yeah so it
melted through and got V choice other
than pretty dirty pretty sticky so
that's I'm wondering how do you barbecue
how do you even know her oh no barbecues
easy bro
barbecue is exactly so is a [ __ ] maid
pie that you just have to know but
barbecue is there's no ten there's no
nothing you put the meat on the grill
and then it's actually what he did with
the pies right if anything that's what I
did i barbecued the pie and you know
what I shouldn't have okay I was wrong I
got you oh so funny it's true you should
do your barbecue sessions again I know I
miss barbecuing did your interview I did
but I don't have my grill and barbecue
anymore where is it oh yeah just sell it
no well can bought it for me for my
birthday and when I take it back
I gave it back cuz I mind but what's the
point I can't take it to the apartment
cuz you know I moved to downtown yeah
yeah but I do kind of miss it though we
should do a beauty queue before the
summer's over guys
oh well it's not over yet we have a
month left yeah and by the time this
video comes out park out I gotta come we
could do it another backyard but I'm
down you eat me I'm desperate I do yes
okay great you can do it if you said no
I would have been like ultimate your
dirt bike yard yeah no one's falling
with each other it was a charity event
long time ago all right
remember the soccer game that was fun
when I had my shaved head you shaved
your head yep
what aside like Gio Jane [ __ ] no no no
no just decide it was a side shave hmm
it was like now but then just the side
is no I just met him like two years ago
three usually three years ago that felt
like it wasn't that long ago oh really
yeah it was yeah I know your hair went
from blue to not too blue what are the
baby with purple oh I think you did
that's what it was it was purple purple
too not she's going through the rainbow
so next I want to do pink you do do does
that actually hurt your hair like does
it damage it damages it a lot it cries
and you're still going pink you only
live once what the [ __ ] no that's tight
do you have you ever done dad I have
that it read huh it's already oh no not
really
so you went back to Metro there - I know
it's blonde oh [ __ ] it like really
damaged my hair and then I'm now just
black said I'm black you should go snow
cone girl wait you dye your hair black
cuz my hair was like brown like because
I was born and then faded to brown why
didn't we get back to go haha yeah I
just thought your hair was black who's
your agent well my wife says she's like
my hair is not black and I'm like oh my
god Nikki your hair's [ __ ] black and
she's like it's not it it's dark brown
and I'm like it's [ __ ] black it's
pretty black it's really dark I'm like
when I pull a hair out of the fridge
it's black oh dude they're everywhere
dude my fridge so where yours is just
yours are blonde and small yeah they're
blonde or whatever that color is dirty
blonde it's turning brown I think yes
something something's going on I think
it's just more of my scalp is invisible
I think that's the only thing that no
the side ones I'll take it I'll take it
it's a compliment I guess
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]